[Applause]
let's talk about this trey songz thing
man we just watched a video of
trey songz altercation with the police
at the kansas city chiefs game
and um this one is tricky man
this is i mean they're all tricky but
this is also tricky this is tricky if
you watch the video no volume
you're like trey is crazy what the [ __ ]
why would you watch a cop this is in
character for trey he be wilin
yeah like does he he is here like wild
story wow boy
wow boy so he i mean like if you just
watching no volume you're like he did
everything wrong here like it looks like
the cop is trying to
tell him to do something arrest him he's
not complying with him and he punched
the cop in the face and he put the cop
in a headlock and like bent him over the
seat and it's just he looks crazy
yeah but then you listen to the people
in the video
yeah and the fans the guy who's filming
and some other people are going arrest
the cop
arrest the cop he did nothing wrong what
the hell is going on
to me it is super weird that you would
feel comfortable enough to punch a cop
when you know you're getting arrested
like if you're punching the top of the
street and you could run away
that's one thing you're inside a stadium
you're getting arrested
like there's no question like there's
nothing you could do even if you tried
to run out
not gonna happen yeah
you would have to you would either have
to be like out of your mind completely
clinically insane
yeah or believe that what was happening
to you was
so highly illegal that you were gonna be
justified in your action in a court of
law yeah
like you you would you must believe that
what was happening to you is
so illegal that a judge and jury
would think that your actions were
defensible
you know that you're videotaped you know
there's cameras everywhere you know that
there's
not even the people videotaping you know
that the facility itself
is gonna videotape everything is on tape
yeah in this situation
you start hearing the people in the
background they're going yo wrestle
please he did nothing wrong this that
the other there's two completely
different accounts
one account is trey songz wasn't wearing
his mask and he'd been repeatedly asked
by people in the stains
stands and the ushers to put on the mask
he did not comply and then the police
had to come over he still did not comply
and then they get a fight
the the other account from witnesses is
that he was being heckled
by some fans who were in the stands he
tells them
to stop heckling or whatever he probably
talks [ __ ] back
sure he talks [ __ ] back who knows we
don't know this is just the other
account but like
he tells him not and then a policeman
hears him talk [ __ ] to the fans and then
goes and gets physical with trey
yeah seemingly out of nowhere right so
both accounts
very different yep like the complete
opposite
it's just so crazy i mean like i cannot
fathom
you'd have to be so intoxicated and even
then
to get physical with a cop in an
enclosed space that you know
is being videotaped and there is no way
out go
do you have the mask detail no go this
is apparently from the headline that
the altercation began because he refused
to wear a mask yeah that's what
he said one side says that but now the
other side said they were heckling him
based on the
the chiefs based on the game not
i mean you don't heckle somebody about a
mask that's not a heckle right in kansas
city we've been in kansas city they
don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's true but also is that a
heckle like put your mask on that's not
a heckle that's like saying obey the
rules like right
oh no i took it as they were heckling
trey yeah they're heckling
but like they're not i don't consider it
a heckle
if you're asking someone to obey the
rules oh no right like
if if somebody goes hey your car is
parked on the sidewalk you should
probably parallel park it where the
wheels aren't on the sidewalk
you're not like well some guy's heckling
me
right yeah it's it's a function of doing
something you're doing something
totally correct and then someone is
being critical of you yeah
i don't think they're like based on the
chiefs either i think they're just
giving trey song [ __ ] cuz they're drunk
but like a heckler on stage right
you're telling your jokes he interrupts
the show and starts saying things
he shouldn't be doing anything yeah a
person at a show
or a person at a game that's telling you
to obey the rules of the show or game is
completely fine it's like an audience
member being like talking to the mic we
can't hear you that's not a heckler it's
not heckle you're just helpful advice
can't be heard before or like when an
audience member tells the heckler to
shut up
he's not also heckling yeah he's trying
to make sure people right abide by the
rules of the show
that's what i'm saying maybe it was
about the mask who knows if it was about
the mask trey's a [ __ ] idiot
if he wouldn't put on the mask and those
are the rules you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah
you know yeah we just had a super
spreader event but do it in the privacy
of your own studio
yeah okay come on you know yeah we're
out here
100 spread in we got the antibodies bro
i'd be a little outside
i mean upset because it's outside yo but
the reality is
it's their rules it's their rules you
agree to go to the game you don't have
to go to the game
no that's true you don't want to wear a
mask don't go to the game that's true
that's also kansas city is cold
you were going to wear a scarf i
actually love a mask in new york in the
winter
it's bright it's great yeah it's great
yeah it covers your face it's cold you
can't live here
you can't live here no you got to live
you got to go somewhere else
if the game was in tampa let's have a
conversation it's uninhabitable
it's unlivable that's the war that i've
heard used it's uninhabitable
you can't inhabit it yeah you can't
inhabit it
it's it's uninhabitable you can survive
in you could survive
it but that's no way to live nah that's
survival we're trying to inhabit places
yeah yeah so miami here we come
point is i have it in new york i'm just
saying if it's about the mask
he's a [ __ ] idiot if it literally he
just refused to wear the mask
you're a [ __ ] idiot like you go
you're not the one wearing the mask and
you're going to punch the cop
whose job it is to tell you where i'm at
you think the cop wants you to wear the
mask
the cop is coming out he's like are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah i gotta ask this
guy
to put on a [ __ ] mask this is what i
when i was young and i dreamed of being
a cop
and i was gonna stop crime and now i'm
mask patrol
yeah real talk if it's about the heckler
he's an idiot
keep going like okay let's say a cop
comes up to you and
puts his hands on you and you don't know
where it's coming from like
the cop has a gun and he's in his head
he thinks he's doing it for a reason
i wouldn't first instinct is to go punch
the cop i'd be like hey hold up what
you're doing
tell me why i'm being detained yes not
fight back with the cop and give him a
reason to escalate things further
yes even if it's unwarranted it's a
shitty position to be in
i've been in it but that was just a dumb
thing to do yeah i mean look
at this would never fight a cop
i'm talking from experience no you're
the guy to judge
you're the guy i mean i'm keeping it
real yes you've learned you've changed
you've evolved
you weren't this is your connor greater
moment yeah that was absolutely good
so look yes andrew's fault though it's
my fault completely
i totally agree with you i totally agree
with you don't punch the cop and then
figure it out later
live to die another day exactly
unfortunately that saying
really applies yeah with black people
and the cops but like
you work it out at the station yeah
don't work it out
when you could be dead yeah obviously
you know you're not going to get shot
right there but it seems like a stupid
that's not really obvious the cop he was
had a chokehold in had a gun i mean it
looked like trey had the chokehold on
the cop
no first the cop had trey down then trey
punches him and then
trey like flips it on some ufc [ __ ] he
really did
i think sucks yeah that guy sucks at all
the cop he absolutely
you needed the sheriff to come in there
and do the job why does trey songs like
the fight
you got a little booger right there i
was gonna
tell you but the camera wouldn't have
seen it but but he likes to fight damn
that thing was that big you could see it
right so he's a wild boy yeah
i know it was wild but what what like
legal [ __ ] i don't know what i'm saying
assaults and all that stuff like i
remember my friend told me that he saw
trey uh smack
the phone out of a girl's hand because
the girl was like oh i mean you're not
august
supposedly like it's august but
you'll do something like that and he got
mad at that's hilarious wow so he gets a
little emotional about [ __ ] yeah
i mean look was that girl jada why the
[ __ ]
but yeah i don't know we gotta we gotta
we gotta see what ends up happening with
this but like
a precedent is gonna be set you can't
put your hand on the officer and the
thing about this is like that's
years that's a felony yeah right we're
talking about
what is that ten years five to ten years
i think it's a
minor felony depending on the case
because it was like a resistance it
one thing is resisting arrest another
thing is attacking an officer
he punched that officer in the face
there's a clear strike
yeah a good lawyer would be like this is
part of the uh resisting arrest
it's not gonna it's not gonna help him
though because i'm reading some of his
uh his other legal issues
on wikipedia 2016 following her
performance in detroit
he was arrested and charged with felony
assault of a police officer
oh so he's got a history of assaulting
police officers and misdemeanor for
aggravated assault against a
photographer oh it's over treyson's
going to jail
and the the cop alleged in a lawsuit he
had a career-ending brain injury and had
to go
undergo a hip replacement because songs
punched him in the face oh get that
money bro
that's all about collecting that check
come on yo that's
that's what the swedish guy tried to do
against me from he wanted that check
yeah
yeah hilarious so he wanted to claim
that he couldn't go back to work yeah he
was like oh i had headaches for weeks
the way i beat his ass it hurt my head
for so long i got connected come on
i connected
is that a win or a loss that's a loss
okay you take that as an l yeah that was
a huge loss
got bullied by a little swede oh shut up
my man was you guys
bullied they pushed you right out the
way
i tripped the guy chased him down from
the back you tripped
chased him down how'd you trip him i
loved
you not outrun the cops though you could
not run sounds like this cop beat the
[ __ ] out of both of you all guys yeah he
was a pretty good
he was in pretty good shape keep going
he was in pretty good shape he was in
pretty good shape
you were in pretty good shape yeah but
he was the best he was in pretty better
i'm proud of that because i need him to
walk through the arm so that you can get
your shot off
son have you ever seen a swede in the
track i got the punch off first no i put
the arm there so that cause because you
were slow with your punches
i got the punch off no you were going to
tell these lies yo
you ain't going to tell these lies stop
the guy so the punch would hit him
notice i put my arm above where his arms
are he was about to block the [ __ ] out
of both of your punches and
just piece you up i just couldn't have
that happen to my boy
so you punched him and then you ran
right and then i chased him down from
behind bro i
hawked him that's what they call it i'm
mad because the fans are gonna hear this
and believe you're dumb
and i tripped him i tripped him he fell
in his face
after tripping him yep i gave you ample
room to run away
son you lost a fight and a race to a
side then he wife over to their side and
was like damn these guys are crazy these
[ __ ] americans
i saw that i didn't say that he switched
sides so he wouldn't get jumped just
said americans
i did what do you mean african to that
yeah yeah
you disappointed your race though yeah
you lose a foot race to a
swede yo have a foot race because people
being like i just need to recover for
alex now
oh [ __ ] you need to race alex that's
what we need to have
it was unbelievable i remember watching
him i remember watching him run away
right and i and i literally go i go
run out come on i have to tell him to
run because i thought he could go faster
than that was like him running in a
dream like he's kind of in place
super slow it was being molasses and the
security guards were coming from all
sides no they weren't yes they were
back towards the security there was six
security guards there kind of mission
impossible
it was security guards i was on a graph
ball was holding me
can i talk to you for a minute verbally
literally
all them off you what i did was heroic
though it's
unbelievable no one was filming this
was a race to a sweet dog yeah that was
embarrassing
for that give me one swedish gold
medalist in track ever
ever true drew really bill better check
that situation you really didn't
like it bro oh [ __ ] you really can't
miss that [ __ ] son
embarrassing that's what happens under
bill belichick seriously honestly
honestly it was true because i thought
he was going to be able to audible
i didn't realize that i had to make all
the decisions for him when i said run i
thought he was going to run away from
all the other yeah
the right play oh yeah you ran towards
them
i had no clue why you did that answer is
the defense his answer has always
been like he he goes he goes he goes how
do you know where to go i didn't
there's one way to not go sorry you you
could know where to not go
yeah you don't go where all the people
are they're trying to [ __ ] you in that
moment you all know what's going on
yes you do you see billy clubs and you
run away from the building
but then more came no no they didn't
right they did that's why i hit the
u-turn
bro you went and then they [ __ ]
called it yo
like he's in europe and there's bad guys
coming in the corner
look at this right here here's the club
right here are we in a wide so they can
see it yeah go to the wide seat you can
see it
this is the club fight goes out down the
street here
i create the separation between him and
the guy trying to beat him up i
literally created the separation i kick
his [ __ ] tool away yeah he has no
billy club he has no nothing he's
falling on the ground because i've
tripped him
yeah yeah all me he had a positive club
versus my hands right
just want to let you all be mostly i did
that and then
al i go run ow right yeah
al runs three feet
in the opposite direction he runs three
feet away from the club
and then he realized he goes oh i
haven't been hit in the head enough no
then i realized there's any more
security guards coming from that side
then i turned the other way where did it
come from where would they come from
over there it's a mcdonald's
what are you talking about he's right
across the street he literally ran
back in front and he got tackled right
in front
of the club literally all these guys
members crazy i heard them talking to
each other
is he stupid what a stupid guy running
right back to us
making it so easy for us literally they
were saying that to each other they
couldn't believe it they couldn't
believe it bro
so i'm going to let you get it off it's
true bro
it's embarrassing you got caught by
white people dog swedes you're a black
african-american black man shut up i
know you slow ball
all right
you